Excellent, so Stream ist am Start.
Machen wir mal Update, bis Twitch kapiert, dass der Stream on ist, ja exquisite Passwort,
kann keiner erraten, super secret, kommt nie jemand drauf.
Ich kann nur den Firefox Update sonst nichts, nämlich verappeln, kann doch gar nicht sein.
Normalerweise updater doch immer riesen Berge an Paketen.
Okay, wenn ich riesen Berge an Paketen updaten will, dann muss ich einfach mal ein JavaScript
aktualisieren, dann ist erst mal das halbe Internet am downloaden.
So, das haben wir noch vom letzten Mal auf, oh ich muss den Chat noch aufmachen, sehe
ich grad hier, exquisite Chat muss geöffnet werden, yes, wir haben heute die Big Brain
Musik am Start, ihr hört es vielleicht schon.
Ah, yes, für noch mehr Gehirn, exzellent Gehirnwachstums Soundtrack, ein dicker Leiser,
oh vielleicht noch, exzellent, so Chat, was gibt es neues, erzähl mir irgendwas
spannendes, irgendwas, ist irgendwas passiert, dieser Desktop, ich hab, ich find das so
geil, ich muss, wenn ich will, wenn ich will, dass der Chat was sagt, muss ich einfach nur
meinen Desktop zeigen, bam, dieser Desktop, null W, warum kann eigentlich, pass mal auf,
warum kann der Windows, dieses Windows Image View Ding keine Bilder zoomen, also Bilder
zoomen kann er, aber GIF zoomen kann er nicht, das ist doch mega schlecht, okay, auf der
anderen Seite, was wundert mich, was wundert mich, was dieser komische Windows Image Viewer
kann, warum zappelt das so rum, ich versuche einfach nur rein zu zoomen und das ist übelst
am rumspacken, das Bild, wo ist das Problem Windows, warum kommt Windows mit reinzoomen
ich klar, all diese mitgelieferten Windows-UWP-Dinger, die sind so dermaßen schlecht, das ist der
Wahnsinn, ne geupdatet haben wir schon, wenn du noch einen Pull-Request hast, dann hast
du Urlaub, exquisite, so muss das sein, wir basteln jetzt noch was für mein Kameraüberwachungstool,
aber das gute ist, wenn wir das gemacht haben, dann ist es mehr oder weniger erstmal, ich
will nicht sagen fertig, weil fertig ist sowas ja nie, aber zumindest hat es dann erstmal
mehr oder weniger basic mäßig alles drin, was es haben soll, geht das bei Linux mit
dem reinzoomen, was, mit den Bildern, keine Ahnung, ich mach Bilder unter Linux so im Browser
drauf, da geht es auf jeden Fall, das ist das beste Logo, also ich finde, es gibt, ah ok
Firefox muss ich restarten, wir haben auch exquisite Beethoven im Hintergrund, ich weiß
gar nicht warum, weil Bing Image of the Day, Image of the Day hat das halt, ja bestes Logo,
guckt es euch mal an, guckt, da geht Bilder zoomen, überhaupt kein Problem, das hat der
Serious Max aus dem Chat gemacht, das Logo und das ist schon, das Logo ist schon wieder
so schlecht, dass es gut ist, das lasse ich auch so, was benutze ich da eigentlich für
eine Distro, ich glaube, wir haben Ausrufezeichen Linux, das ist mal ein Jaro mit I3WM als Window
Manager, aber ich glaube, wir haben Ausrufezeichen Linux als Kommando, wo man glaube ich noch
ein bisschen mehr sieht, nee ok, vergiss es, man sieht nicht mehr, das ist im Prinzip gelauert,
das was ich gerade gesagt habe, dachte wir haben da vielleicht ein Kommando mit einem
Link zum Stream, wo wir das aufgesetzt haben oder so, aber was auch immer, aber wenn dich
die Konfics interessieren, ich hab mal vor einer Weile auf GitHub ein paar Konfics hochgeladen,
wobei das nicht so wirklich das allerletzte vom Stand her ist, aber so halbwegs, da tut
sich ja nicht so viel, ne.
So Leute, also ich zeige euch mal, was ich getan habe seit dem letzten Mal, was empfiehlst
du für eine Distro, wenn man nicht I3 will, kommt drauf an, wenn du Einsteiger bist, dann
gibt es, finde ich, eigentlich erstmal nichts, was gegen Linux Mint spricht, auch wenn ich
es mir letztens angeguckt habe und ich jetzt nicht so wahnsinnig davon begeistert war, Ubuntu
Desktop mag ich gar nicht, das ist ja mehr oder weniger Ubuntu mit einem schöneren
Desktop, ansonsten kannst du dir auch noch Elementory angucken, wenn du auf ein bisschen
Mac OS Style stehst oder wenn dich ein China Linux nicht stört, dann kannst du Deepin
verwenden, aber wenn du dir nicht viele Gedanken machen willst, dann nimm einfach Linux Mint
mit Cinnamon, wie auch immer man das ausspricht, Desktop, wenn du auf einer echten Kiste das
laufen lassen willst und wenn du das in der VM laufen lassen willst, dann nimm XFCE.
Ah yes, guck mal, bei dieser Musik da wächst mein Gehirn schon wieder, Leute, spürt ihr
das auch, wenn das läuft, dann geht das auseinander, der Kopf, bis nichts mehr reinpasst.
Ah yes, Vollkornmisch pro 10 Monate, danke schön für den Sub, hast du auch so Comet
Messages auf der Arbeit, was meinst du für Comet Messages, du meinst sowas hier, du
meinst sowas hier, oder, oder Moment, oder meinst du vielleicht sowas hier als Comet
Messages, ja, die habe ich teilweise auf der Arbeit auch, aber ich werde das, zumindest
meistens werde ich das dann immer repasen oder resetten, bevor es wirklich irgendwo
reinkommt, aber ja, manchmal, also es ist mir auch schon die ein oder andere Comet Message
durchgerutscht, die tatsächlich 0W oder sowas dummes hatte, aber das ist nix gegen die Leute,
wir hatten mal einen, es war sogar der Felix, den kennt ihr, mit dem habe ich mal ein Gamescom
Video gemacht, vor 50 Jahren oder so, und der hat mal ein paar Comets gemacht, fucking
shit geht, verpiss dich geht oder sowas, und die sind auch im Repo genannt, irgendwie hat
er sich, irgendwie war er frustriert, weil was nicht funktioniert hat, hast du hier schon
Blackarch angeguckt, nee, habe ich noch nicht, klingt wie irgendein Hacker, ah ja, Penetration
Testing Distribution, exellent, nee, habe ich noch nicht ausprobiert, is Blackarch better
than Kali, nee gut, wenn die Slunt Community was recommended, das heißt ja schon mal gar
nix, null, who cares Slunt, alter, wen interessiert das Billship, was die Typen da schreiben,
habt ihr auch schon mal euch danach gerichtet, was die Slunt Community abstimmt, das ist
irgendwie so eine Rankings Seite, wo er verschiedene Sachen Up und Down voten kann, aber total
unbedeutend irgendwie, das ist genauso schwach wie Distro Watch, Distro Watch, als ich noch
nicht wusste, wie die ihre Beliebtheit ermitteln, ich habe es schon wieder vergessen, zumindest
früher wusste ich nicht, wie die ihre Beliebtheit ermitteln, und da dachte ich immer, aha, hier
danach kann man sich so richten, und dann habe ich zwischenzeitlich rausbekommen, wie die
ihre Beliebtheit der letzten, der Linux Distros ermitteln, und seitdem denke ich mir, ist voll
für einen Arsch, ich bin mir nicht mehr sicher, wie die es machen, ich glaube die machen
das, irgendwas was über ihre Seite läuft, also ganz merkwürdige Metrik, also im Prinzip
juckt es gar keinen, überhaupt nicht, gar nicht, null, was die Typen sagen, ja so eine
wirklich gute Übersichtseite für Linux Sachen gibt es nicht, also keine, wo man wirklich
mal eine gute Übersicht über Distros hätte, wo man dann sagen kann, ja, ich suche nach,
was weiß ich, eine Server Distro, eine Desktop Distro, einsteige, es gibt ein paar Listen,
die Leute gemacht haben, also was wirklich Gutes, ja, eigentlich, zumindest fällt mir
als nichts ein, was würdest du für Linux Server Distros vorschlagen, auf den dein Gameserver
laufen soll, musst du da drauf irgendwas Supportedes laufen lassen, also sprich, bist
du, keine Ahnung, willst du da auf Battlefield 4 Server hausten oder irgendwas, also, ne wahrscheinlich
nicht, Battlefield 4 geht ja gar nicht, also sprich, wenn du irgendwas Supportedes drauf
laufen lassen willst, wo der Hersteller nur bestimmte Sachen zertifiziert, dann bist du
mit Red Hat beziehungsweise CentOS ganz gut dabei, aber ansonsten würde ich immer Ubuntu
Server nehmen, mir gefällt Ubuntu Server persönlich am besten, Ubuntu Server ist mir, also wirklich
von allen Distros am liebsten, auf der Arbeit haben wir nur Red Hat, also CentOS, wird übrigens
noch witzig, ja, geht richtig gut, Battlefield 3, ne, ich hab gestern auch noch mal ein paar
Runden gespielt, ich wollte eigentlich streamen, aber ich hab mir gedacht, ey komm, jetzt ganz
entspannt mal ohne streamen, ok Leute, was ist jetzt los, wieso nicht Debian, hat keinen
speziellen Grund, ist persönlicher Geschmack, kannst genauso gut Debian nehmen, Alter, ich
hab vor, frag mich nicht, 3 Stunden was gegessen, es kann doch jetzt nicht sein, dass ich irgendwie
da, Moment, jetzt gehts, also ich zeig euch mal kurz, ich zeig euch mal kurz was ich getan
hat hier, das ist noch die Sachen vom letzten Mal, ich hab nur ein paar Kleinigkeiten angepasst,
also man sieht, das funktioniert immer noch, also die Bewegungserkennung tut noch, wenn
einer durchs Bild läuft, warte mal mal, zeig euch das mal, weil die so nicht gesehen haben,
ja, die läuft, King Ball die läuft bei mir schon, mit allen 5 echten Kameras, deswegen
muss ich auch ein paar Sachen anpassen, weil Safari mal wieder rumgebackt hat, oh ja, das
kann ich euch zeigen, weil ich für Safari anpassen musste, 1337 SQLite Explorer, probier's
mal damit, das ist bestimmt eine SQLite Datenbank, ok, exquisite Musik hier im Hintergrund, hört
sich fast an als wäre es irgendwelche Wiener Klassik oder sowas, du weißt es ist da eine
andere Soundtrack, also wie gesagt hier, Motion Erkennung, so funktioniert alles, so ich musste
aber eine Sache für Safari anpassen und ich bin zu dumm das anarbeitet zu machen, Safari,
wahrscheinlich nur, äh, nutzt du da fertige KI Zeugs, ja, ja, SQLite Browser schon probiert
ja, dann ist was anderes, dann mach mal das hier, guck mal, äh, wenn du auf dem Lidungstest,
mach mal das hier, guck, hier ist meine SQLite Datenbank, mach mal das hier, Pfeil, Pfeil,
dann zeigt er dir an, höchstwahrscheinlich was es für eine Datei ist, allerdings.db
kann halt alles sein, ne, SQLite, ich nenn die Dinger nur.db, aber.db kann ja alles
sein, wie gesagt, wie der Chat sagt von Axis, bis Oracleite, falls es sowas gibt, so, also,
ok ich zeig euch mal was ich für Safari machen musste, es ist wieder absolut abenteuerlicher
Shit, ja, also, hier, das ist der Code für alle anderen Browser und das ist der Code
für Safari, weil, weil Safari übelst rumspackt, wenn ich, also was ich hier mache ist, ich
bau hier die Verbindung zum Backend auf für die Videos, ja, was er im Detail macht, was
er im Detail macht ist egal, aber das geile ist, bei jedem anderen Browser kann ich einfach
sagen, ok, Streams für die jeweilige Kamera ID speichern und gut ist, funktioniert, gar
kein Problem, Safari nicht und ich hab nicht verstanden warum und ich hab nicht rausbekommen
warum, wenn ich diese Seite mit Safari aufmach, dann laden random Videos nicht, die Videos
hängen random, also die bleiben halt immer auf loading, ja, so random, mal gehts, mal
gehts nicht, total wirbt, so und irgendwann hab ich dann so halbwegs was rausgefunden
was es sein könnte, wenn man in Safari mehrere Videoplayer gleichzeitig startet, dann gehen
random Videoplayer nicht, also sprich, wenn du fünf Videoplayer auf eine Seite machst
und machst da ein Button hin und dieser Button macht in allen Videoplayern Play, dann hängen
random eins von fünf oder zwei von fünf oder mal auch gar keins, Videos unter Safari, so
und das ist ja das was ich hier im Endeffekt mache, ich bau eine Verbindung auf für die
zu den einzelnen Kameras im Backend, oder das stimmt ja nicht, zu meinem Backend was
die Kameras streamt, das ist nein, das ist nicht das Auto-Play-Block-Feature, wie gesagt,
es geht ja darum, dass die Sachen von Hand ausgelöst werden und wenn die Sachen nicht
von Hand ausgelöst werden, so wie hier, dann muss man in Safari sagen, dass die Dinger,
das ist auch so ein Safari-Ding, das ist auch so ein Safari-Ding, hier guck mal, Auto-Play,
du musst einmal, muted musst du auf allen Plattformen sagen, also wenn du Video automatisch
abspielen willst, musst du auch unter Android sagen, dass das Video muted ist, weil die
wollen halt vorbeugen, dass irgendwelche Webseiten Werbung mit Sound machen, das kann
die auch verstehen, das ist auch so ein Apple-Ding, Place-In-Line, niemand braucht das außer
iOS, weil Apple, ich hab keine Ahnung, was es genau macht, ja, aber Place, guck mal,
der Auto-Completed noch nicht mal Place-In-Line, der kennt das gar nicht, aber das braucht
man, sonst geht es unter Apple nicht, äh, Refit-Trainerin, das ist eine gute Frage,
das kommt öfters auf, warum willst du das überhaupt für Safari haben, für dein iPhone,
ja im Prinzip, dass man iOS unterstützen kann, aber kannst du da keinen anderen Browser
nehmen, nein, kann man nicht, das ist auch was, was viele Leute nicht wissen, unter
iOS gibt es keinen anderen Browser, du wirst jetzt wahrscheinlich sagen, aber ich kann
doch, keine Ahnung, Firefox und Chrome unter iOS installieren, aber das ist fake, es gibt
keinen Chrome und kein Firefox unter iOS, das ist alles Safari, Apple erlaubt keine
andere Web-Engine unter iOS als Safari, also sprich, was Firefox und Chrome machen ist,
die nehmen ein Safari und machen einfach einen Chrome-GUI drumherum, also sprich, das da
im Apple Store, nicht Apple Pay, Alter, das da ist gar kein Chrome, also wer gedacht hat,
das ist ein Chrome, der hat die Rechnung ohne Apple gemacht, deswegen funktionieren ja auch
so viele Sachen nicht unter iOS und Chrome, die unter anderem Betriebssystem funktionieren,
ja, ja, unter Android hast du, wobei unter Android hast du das Problem mittlerweile teilweise
auch, weil Google auch nicht so scharf drauf ist, dass andere Browserhersteller Dinger machen,
zum Beispiel musste Firefox, Firefox musste ein Video-Codex entfernen, weil Google gesagt
hat, ihr dürft das sonst nicht über den Store vertreiben, das war natürlich ein Video-Codex,
den Firefox unterstützt hat, den Google-Chrome nicht kannte, nicht kannte, tja, ne, so ist
das unter Apple, also wer mir das nicht glaubt, kann das auch nachgucken, ja, also unter iOS
ist alles Apple, alles Safari, so, das heißt, wenn ich das unter Chrome laufen lasse, dann
geht das nicht und um iOS zu unterstützen, muss ich also zwingen, mir bleibt gar nichts
anderes übrig, das hab ich jetzt eigentlich gerade gemacht, also Plays Inline, die bleibt
gar nichts anderes übrig, wie Safari zu unterstützen, so, und damit Safari funktioniert, wie gesagt,
das ist der Code für jeden anderen Browser und das hier ist der Special Code für Safari,
weil Safari ein Problem hat, wenn zu viele Videos gleichzeitig starten, dann hängen
random Videos und die recovern auch nicht, die bleiben einfach hängen, ich hab nichts
dazu gefunden im Internet, ich hab keine Ahnung, was das ist, ich weiß nur, dass es
unter iOS 13 geht und unter iOS 14 geht das nicht, also ich vermute mal, das ist ein Bug
von iOS 14, aber dazu hab ich auch nichts gefunden, also unter, ich hab ja noch ein
altes iPhone 6, da geht's sofort, ohne Probleme, hängt auch nicht, iOS 14 auf dem iPad und
auf dem neuen iPhone geht nicht, wie testest du Safari unter nicht macOS iOS Betriebssystem,
äh, unter iOS Betriebssystem, test ich das, ich hab hier dein iPhone liegen oder dein
iPad wahlweise und dann probier ich das einfach aus, ja, so und was man machen muss, damit
der ganze Shit funktioniert bei Apple ist folgendes, also, erste Mal darf man nicht
einfach nur das Video setzen, wie bei allen anderen Browsern, also was der hier unter
der Haube macht ist, der baut eine Verbindung auf zum Backend und holt sich diesen Videostream,
ist ganz vereinfacht gesagt, so und, ähm, dann nimmt er diesen Videostream, nimmt die
ID von der Kamera und hängt das an so ein globales Streams-Objekt an mit der Kamera-ID
dabei, im Prinzip sorgt das dafür, dass die Videoplayer das Video finden und das abspielen
können, so, das ist der Code für jeden anderen Browser, das ist der Code für Safari, weil
Safari übelst rumspackt, muss ich jetzt folgendes machen, erstmal muss ich gucken, ob es Safari
ist, wenn es Safari ist, muss ich einen Tick von meinem JavaScript-Framework warten, weil,
weil das bringt was, hab ich gemerkt, ja, ich hab ganz viel Try and Error gemacht, das
bringt was, so und jetzt, dass keine Videos zusammen anfangen zu playen, muss ich folgen,
das ist echt Haare sträuben, ne, ich muss dafür sorgen, dass nicht so viele Videos gleichzeitig
anfangen zu playen, weil sonst Safari hängt, also nicht Safari hängt, die Videos im Safari
hängen, deswegen mach ich folgendes, ich warte 5 Millisekunden plus einen Random Timeout
von 1 bis 500 Millisekunden, so und sollte es dann doch mal vorkommen, dass Videos zu
gleichzeitig starten, dann hab ich noch einen Retry eingebaut, der alle 5 Sekunden nochmal
retried, falls Safari hängt und ja, ich weiß, dass ich einen Sleep-Trenner hab, was man
in JavaScript nicht machen sollte und was es in JavaScript eigentlich auch gar nicht gibt,
aber ist mir egal, es funktioniert, ja und ich hab ehrlich gesagt keinen plassen Schimmer,
warum?
Dass nur in Safari so ist, aber man muss es machen, sonst spackt es in Safari rum und
die Videos hängen, richtig fail, richtig fail, guckt euch mal meine Massive, mein Massive
Sleep fängt schon an für JavaScript an, nee aber, also warum Safari das Problem hat, weiß
ich nicht, weil Safari in iOS 13 hat das Problem nicht, was man vielleicht machen sollte ist,
ich sollte mal upgraden, gestern oder vorgestern kam doch irgendwie neues iOS raus, doch Florian
kann ich, ich kann einfach ne Schleife drüber machen, aber ich hab das programmiert, hab
festgestellt, es funktioniert und hab es einfach nochmal drunter copypastet und fass es nicht
mehr an, das bleibt jetzt so, so lang Safari, achja, achja, achja Moment, ich hab euch ja
noch was, ich muss euch ja noch was zeigen, das ist ja noch nicht, das ist ja noch nicht
alles, was man für Safari braucht, Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment, wo hab ich's denn,
man braucht noch was, man braucht noch spezielles für Safari, zwar das hier, das funktioniert
jetzt auch nicht richtig, so genau und eh, also, also was das macht ist, wenn es auf
einem mobilen Gerät ist und man raus tappt, wenn man aus dem, also sprich wenn ich so
mach auf dem mobilen Gerät, ja, also ich, ich mach die Anwendung auf dem mobilen Gerät
zu und geh wieder hin, dann bekommt das Safari nicht mit, so und was das Ding macht ist,
das merkt sich die Zeit, glaub ich zumindest, was auch immer ich da gemacht hab, wieso mischt
du CamelCase und SnakeCase, weil das entweder copypastet von StackOverflow ist oder ich
das von was altem kopiert hab, so und zumindest muss man sich irgendwie die Zeit merken, wann
man zuletzt auf der Seite war und wenn der Intervall größer ist als frag mich nicht,
dann muss ich die Seite reloaden, weil Safari nicht mitbekommen hat, dass ich die Anwendung
auf und zu gemacht hab, ganz abartiges Zeug, ich hab, wie gesagt, ich hab, das hab ich
nur für Safari drin und wo hab ich das andere jetzt und den Shit hab ich nur für Safari
drin, ey frag mich, das geht mir echt auf den Sack, auf jeder anderen Plattform funktioniert
es, in jedem anderen Browser funktioniert es aber iOS und Safari macht nicht, weil was
ansonsten in Safari passiert ist, wenn ihr die Anwendung einfach minimiert, also ihr
switcht raus und geht wieder hin, dann ist der so clever, dass man eigentlich reconnecten
müsste, aber der reconnectet nur halb, der lädt irgendwie die halbe Seite aus dem Cache
und die andere Hälfte nicht und es funktioniert nicht, so und mit dem anderen mach ich halt
Force Reload, ist zwar nicht schön, weil Safari dadurch 3 Sekunden nachdem man die App kurz
minimiert hat und wieder aufmacht, 3 Sekunden noch mal alles lädt, aber es funktioniert
wenigstens, was auch immer, Hauptsache es geht, ist mir wurscht, ich hab kein Bock da
noch, ich hab da teilweise, ich hab insgesamt bestimmt 2 Tage dran rumgewurstet, bis der
Scheiß in Safari richtig funktioniert hat und das war nicht das einzig, ich hab einiges
umgebaut, dass Safari ordentlich funktioniert, den Kram können wir raus machen, der hat
glaub ich keinen tieferen Sinn, genau und was jetzt noch fehlt ist folgendes, also was
ich geändert hab, was ich geändert hab zum letzten Mal ist das hier, man kann jetzt hier
draufklicken, 500 Millisekunden, also ich kann draufklicken oder Touch machen, also sprich
wenn ich, das ist mein Groß, also sprich wenn ich Touch Action mache mit dem Handy, dann
geht halt das auf, oh ihr habt übrigens gesehen, die Buttons sind mittlerweile, sind mittlerweile,
wie nennt man es denn, Responsive Buttons, ja jetzt, guck mal hier, sind sie groß und
jetzt zack sind sie klein, exellent, so, gibt jetzt hier ein Menü, kann man draufklicken,
wenn man die Kamera editieren will, dann geht das auf und dann kann man zum Beispiel sagen,
ok ich will die Kamera löschen oder ich will zum Beispiel ändern, ich will Sachen an der
Kamera ändern, kann man, wenn mir fällt übrigens gerade auf, eine Sache sollte ich vielleicht
hier noch einbauen, weil ich kann die Kamera löschen, ich kann das updaten, aber ich sollte
vielleicht nen Skip-Button einbauen, ja ich kann einfach update drücken, hier hab ich
nen Skip-Button, vielleicht soll ich nochmal nen Skip-Button einbauen, ich hab ne Idee,
oh Big Brain, wartet mal, das können wir richtig nice machen, aber wir können, das können
wir einstrahlt machen, der Update-Button ist nen Skip-Button, solange keiner was macht,
kann man da auch die Motion Detection aktivieren, ja kann man machen, sogar, sogar richtig, sogar
richtig äh, äh, sozusagen so, äh nicht Multithreaded sogar, äh, also so richtig modern, ja also
sprich wenn du, wenn du jetzt hingehst und sagst ok, ich hoffe das funktioniert jetzt,
ich hab nämlich vorher dran rumgebaut, ich hoffe es nicht, ich hab es nicht kaputt gemacht,
wenn du jetzt hingehst und sagst, aha hier ist, also hier siehst du die Motion Detection
ist aus, sagst ok, ich will da nix ändern, aha das ist noch kaputt, das ist doof, der
reloadet wenn man das update, das sackt natürlich, das ist nicht gut, ok das ist nicht gut,
zumindest kann man jetzt die Motion Detection anmachen und wie du siehst, ist die jetzt
an und jetzt ist sie wieder aus, warum reloadet der denn die Kameras, der soll die Kameras
eigentlich gar nicht reloaden, aber du siehst, dass das funktioniert, also sprich wenn du
in den Settings das an und ausschaltest, dann reloadet der das überall automatisch und
macht das, ähm, warum er die Kameras reloadet ist mir nicht ganz klar, ich glaub das muss
ich noch abfangen, wenn sich nix geändert hat, dass er nicht reloadet oder so, muss
ich mal gucken, mal schauen, bind mal Kingwall, das klingt nach Monkathos, da war es einzubinden,
ja also guck du kannst hier schon updaten, jetzt hast du die Motion Erkennung an, zack,
finish, Kunst, so und wenn jetzt hier gleich einer durchs Bild läuft, dann wirst du sehen,
Motion Erkennung funktioniert, kannst du auch wieder ausschalten, hier guck, ah bam, person,
wenn es ausschaltet, dann ist er auch direkt aus, also das funktioniert mittlerweile, ähm,
genau was wir jetzt vielleicht noch machen sollten ist, update, also wenn sich hier und
hier nix geändert hat, dann schreiben wir da nicht update rein, update, ne setup muss
ich, sondern schreiben skip rein, das ist ne gute Idee, das probieren wir mal aus, äh
übrigens nix zu meinem Wizard sagen, ich weiß, dass der mega hässlich ist, aber er
funktioniert, das reicht erstmal, ordentlich kann ich das immer noch machen, also update,
wir können nämlich sagen, dass ähm, wenn ich hier nix editiert hab, dass dann einfach
skip da steht, aber dann, oh, mehr state please, moin, tch, excellent, also dass wir irgendwie
sagen, wenn es update mode ist, dann sagen wir update und wenn, oh ne, oh ne, oh ne, das
ist mir zu eklig, wir wissen alle, dass der Wizard nie ordentlich gemacht wird, was, wie
kommst du auf sowas? oh ne, das ist mir jetzt zu nervig, da müsste ich hier noch nen dritten
Case reinbauen, hier noch nen dritten Case wenn sich nix geändert hat, äh ne ne ne ne
ne, das lassen wir jetzt erstmal, halt, das muss ich mir mal was anderes was ordentliches
überlegen, naja, zumindest, das funktioniert mittlerweile, man kann Kameras löschen, was
Was machst du gerade? Ich versuche heute eine finale Sache einzubauen in diese Kamerasoftware, die ich noch unbedingt drin haben will und dann mache ich die Sache bis Weihnachten noch ein bisschen hübsch, genau, weil du kannst ja noch die Position nicht verschieben.
Also aktuell ist es so, die Kameras sind immer in der Position, wo du sie hinzugefügt hast.
Aber sprich, wenn du die Kamera jetzt von unten nach oben moveen willst, das geht ja aktuell nicht. Was ziemlich doof ist, weil vielleicht willst du ja auf einmal diese Kamera oben haben und die unten.
Sprich, also das müssen wir irgendwie einbauen.
Genau, ich zeige jetzt mal, dass prinzipiell die Sache funktioniert, also sprich, man kann das löschen, geht man hier hin, sagt Delete, ah, bla bla bla, ok, beste Abfrage aller Zeiten, ok, zack, Kamera ist weg.
Ähm, Aufnahme und so funktioniert auch immer noch.
Aufnahme an, Aufnahme aus, wenn man sich die Aufnahme angucken will, dann hier, achso, ja das geht nicht. Ah, lul, lul weh.
Die habe ich vorhin gelöscht von Hand, die Aufnahmen, die sind da gar nicht drin. Aber ihr seht, also Aufnahmen abspielen funktioniert auch.
Habe ich gerade eben aufgenommen, hier, 18.12.3i, warum ist das Kokona Datum?
Ja gut, wahrscheinlich weil mein Browser auf Englisch eingestellt ist.
So, also Aufnahmen abspielen kann man auch.
So, jetzt lösche ich mal die ganzen Kameras, die drinnen sind, Delete, S.
Dein Meme-Emote-Tool ist auch eine Webseite, ne, das hier ist eine WPF-Anwendung.
Eine WPF-Anwendung mit einem Webinterface zum Emotes anklicken. Ja, aber das hier ist eine WPF-Anwendung.
Weil ich habe hier irgendwas gebraucht, was ich overlayen kann.
Ich konvertiere hier gar nichts, das bleibt so.
Ich mache das so, wenn irgendwie einer einen Feature-Request aufmacht und sagt, Datum gefällt ihm nicht, dann sage ich, stelle deinen Browser auf das richtige Format ein, fertig.
Bin ich fein raus.
Ähm, UWP geht nicht. UWP geht nicht, ich habe aber vergessen, woran es lag.
Es hatte einen Grund, warum es nicht UWP ist. Das ging mal wieder nicht und unter UWP funktionieren die meisten Sachen eh nicht gescheit.
So, löschen wir die Kamera auch nochmal, hoffentlich geht das jetzt. Jawoll, exellent.
Ja, das hatte nämlich einen Bug, wenn man Kameras löscht mit Aufnahmen drinnen ist.
So, also, was wir jetzt machen ist, also ich habe gesehen, man kann Kameras jetzt editieren und Kameras löschen und so, also das funktioniert ganz gut.
Was wir jetzt machen müssen ist, RTSP, ich füge mal wieder ein paar Streams.
Hat jemand einen guten RTSP-Test-Stream, wo kein Monkertoss-Zeug läuft?
Weil ich habe lokal, wobei doch, ich kann lokal noch ein paar starten. Wir haben doch, Moment, Moment, wir haben doch hier jede Menge, wir haben doch das Fitnessgrill von YouTube, was wir starten können.
Moment, Stream Flur haben wir, hier MyStream1 brauchen wir jetzt noch.
Was hatten wir noch alles?.ts.
Kingwall, ja, aber die sind alle nicht RTSP, oder?
RTSP-Test-World, gibt es da irgendwie sowas? Das benutzen wir immer.
Webcam, irgendwie City oder so.
Ich trau, ich trau mich nicht, ich trau mich nicht auf die Seiten drauf, Leute.
Ich trau mich, nee, nee, nee, ich geh nicht auf die Seiten, das ist Monkertoss.
Das ist richtig Tost, keine Ahnung, wo man da rauskommt.
Okay, ich muss gerade mal kurz gucken.
Wir haben noch ein paar YouTube-Videos runtergeladen, die wir...
Ja, das ist doch ein YouTube-Video, was wir uns runtergeladen haben, wo man gut ausprobieren kann, als Kamera Fake Stream.
Hätte ich die Dinger mal ordentlich benannt.
Ich könnte ja eigentlich ein Video von mir runterladen, dann ist noch nicht mal Monkertoss.
Lad mal ein Video von mir runter.
Ja, das da.
Excellent.
Ah, die Anno-Musik, ey.
YouTube-DL, ups, YouTube-DL.
YouTube-Videos runterladen, meine eigenen Videos kann ich auch runterladen, wie ich will.
Wenn sich da irgendwie einer beschwert, ist die Anzeige...
What? Ach so.
Was lädt man da runter, dass es am ehesten wie eine Webcam aussieht, 22?
Kann durchaus sein, dass es nicht funktioniert, weil das YouTube H264 muss nicht unbedingt kompatibel mit Web-RTC im Browser sein.
Okay, Weihnachtsnoup sind zurück, nennen wir das jetzt mal youtube.mp4-i.
Das müssen wir jetzt erstmal konvertieren, keine Ahnung.
TS, äh, Copy.
So, excellent.
Okay, schauen wir mal, ob das jetzt funktioniert.
Stream, My Stream 1 und zwar youtube.ts.
Ich habe meine Zweifel, dass es funktioniert.
Also wir probieren es jetzt erstmal mit dem normalen Stream aus.
Also 0W Stream, add.
Emoji Support.
Wo ist Emoji? Ich habe überall Emoji supported.
So, dann machen wir die Bewegungserkennung an.
Zack, Finish, Timer brauchen wir nicht.
So, das ist übrigens auch noch ein Problem, was ich einbauen muss.
Also zwei Sachen muss ich noch einbauen.
Erstens, einen Button zum Kameras hinzufügen, wenn schon eine Kamera drin ist.
Und, dass ich das hoch und runter bewegen kann auf der Seite.
Jetzt waren wir alles in einem. Ich habe auch schon eine Idee, wie wir das am besten machen.
Okay, und jetzt gucken wir mal, ob das funktioniert.
Connected?
Excellent, mein Battlefield-Video funktioniert einfach, hätte ich gar nicht gedacht.
Und jetzt sagt nicht, es läuft ja auch auf Youtube im Browser, dann geht es auch darüber.
Das ist nicht so einfach.
Also das ist ganz speziell, was der unterstützt an Codex, dass es funktioniert.
Es schmiert ein bisschen, aber da kann ich mit leben.
Soll ich da mal Bewegungserkennung anmachen, ob da da irgendwas... Nee, das machen wir jetzt.
Übrigens, das da schmiert, das liegt an diesem kack RTSP-Server, den ich lokal habe.
Wenn ich da mehr als zwei Streams laufen habe, fangen Videos an zu schmieren.
Echte Kameras schmieren nicht.
Okay, also zwei Kameras reichen zum Testen. Jetzt haben wir das Problem.
Ich will jetzt beispielsweise die Kamera hier unten oben haben und die Kamera oben unten.
Das geht ja starrmäßig nicht. Und ich brauche einen Button, wo ich neue Kameras hinzufügen kann,
wenn schon Kameras drin sind, weil wäre ja ziemlich doof, wenn das nicht funktioniert.
Exquisite. Kannst du vielleicht beim Battlefield-Gameplay auch die...
Ich kann es mal probieren. Wollen wir mal gucken, was der erkennt, wenn ich die Bewegungserkennung
in Battlefield anmache?
Nee, da erkennt er nix. Das ist auch zu schnell. Das ist zu schnell. Das kapiert er nicht.
Oh, MonkaS. Das kapiert er nicht, dass das Leute sind.
Also das geht nur wirklich nicht. Der macht ja nur alle zwei Sekunden ein Bild davon
und schickt das an die Objekterkennung. Und dass das Leute sind... Nee, das erkennt er nicht.
Ich weiß, wenn man Glück hat, erkennt man das vielleicht mal, wenn sich was stillsteht
im Bild ist oder so. Die läuft nicht im Frontend. Das ist ein eigener Docker-Container.
Das nennt sich DOOTS nennt sich das. DOOTS. Das ist ein fertiger... Alter, okay, das Video
spackt schon ein bisschen ab von YouTube. Das ist ein fertiger TensorFlow, trainiertes
TensorFlow-Gedöns mit Web API. Den könnt ihr jetzt aber vielleicht erkennen,
wenn wir Glück haben. Äh, vergesst. Also, Game-Erkennung ist nicht seins. Ich bin aber
sogar ganz froh, dass er das nicht erkennt, weil umso weniger so was erkennt, umso weniger
macht er auch irgendwelche Fehlalarme, wenn Leute durchs Bild, äh, wenn Viecher durchs
Bild springen oder sowas. Nee, das erkennt er nicht. Das hätte mich jetzt auch echt
gewundert, wenn er da irgendwas erkennt. Ja, man müsste das beispielsweise mal ausprobieren.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es irgendeine Szene in dem Video gibt, wo ich mal eine Person länger
als 1-2 Sekunden angucke. Ich wollte übrigens demnächst noch eine zweite Objektenerkennung
testen. Also aktuell, aktuell verwenden wir das. Aktuell verwenden wir das hier. Das ist
ein fertiger Docker-Container mit Web API für Bilderkennung. Läuft, funktioniert wunderbar.
Ich habe aber noch was anderes gefunden. Deep Stack nennt sich das Ganze. Deep Stack.
Das da. Nee. Nein. Heads Up Limit Poker. Nein. Guck mal, das Battlefield-Video droppt
wie verrückt irgendwelche, irgendwelche, äh, Pakete. Man sieht es ja auch, guck mal. Ähm,
was wird hier gemacht? Wir haben eine, äh, über die letzten paar Streams schon, also
wir haben eine Software programmiert für Überwachungskameras mit einer Erkennung für
Leute. Und ich habe das gerade mal mit, mit Battlefield-Gameplay von mir getestet. Also
in meinem Battlefield-Gameplay Leute erkennen geht nicht, aber wenn Leute durchs Bild laufen,
so bei einer normalen Kamera, guck hier, sowas zum Beispiel, das erkennt er, wenn eine
Person ins Bild läuft. Wie ist das denn? Deep Stack? Ich habe das gefunden, ich habe
das gefunden, weil ich bei Home Assistant gesucht habe. Deep Stack. Hier, das da. Also
wie gesagt, aktuell verwenden wir das für die Objekterkennung. Wie zuverlässig läuft
das? Also, ich habe es mal ausprobiert. Ich habe das bei mir, genau für diese Kamera
im Hof habe ich das an. Allerdings, das hier ist jetzt nur ein Ausschnitt von 15 Sekunden
von der Kamera im Hof, aber ich habe es laufen für die Kamera im Hof. Und, ähm, wenn ich
hier vorlaufe zum Hoftor, dann erkennt er mich. Oder wenn wir zu zweit vorlaufen zum
Hof, dann erkennt er das auch. Das funktioniert. Man muss sagen, am meisten Probleme hat er
tatsächlich mit Nachtsicht. Also sprich, wenn ich was anhabe, was vom Kontrast her nicht
so richtig passt in der Nachtsicht, dann kann es sein, dass er es nicht erkennt. Tagsüber
erkennt er das eigentlich sehr zuverlässig. Nachts, würde ich sagen, 90%. Allerdings,
muss ich sagen, ich finde es besser, er erkennt es ein bisschen zu wenig als zu viel. Weil
wenn er es zu viel erkennt, hast du laufen irgendwelche Sachen, weil, keine Ahnung, vom
Hoftor einer vorbeiläuft, weil die Bäume wackeln, weil sonst was ist. Das ist nervig.
Für Security Sachen würde ich mich eh prinzipiell auf sowas nicht verlassen. Also wer jetzt
beispielsweise Nachrichten haben will, weil jemand bei ihm daheim einbricht, anhand von
irgendeiner Personenerkennung, da würde ich eh auf was anderes setzen. Da würde ich auf
Fenstertürsensoren setzen oder stinknormale Bewegungssensoren, die nicht versuchen zu erkennen,
was da langläuft. Das ist deutlich zuverlässiger. Du brauchst eine Color... Was? Color... Color...
Ich kann doch keiner aussprechen, Alter. Farblich nachts. Nice. Der Unterschied zu
MotionEye ist, dass MotionEye lahm as fuck ist. Ja. Das ist eigentlich der größte Unterschied.
MotionEye decoded Videos, das hier decoded keine Videos. Also das hier nimmt 1 zu 1 den
Stream, wie es von der Kamera kommt, deswegen kannst du hier auch ein Battlefield-Video
anzeigen lassen. Ich habe hier lokal einen RTSP-Server laufen, was ein Battlefield-Video
von mir streamt. Es ist halt ein stinknormaler RTSP-Server, egal ob das jetzt von der Kamera
kommt oder sonst wie. Und du siehst, das läuft mit... Was haben wir denn hier? Wie viele
Bilder pro Sekunde haben wir denn da überhaupt? Und das läuft mit 30 FPS. Wenn du ein paar
Kameras in MotionEye mit 30 FPS hast, dann ist das Ding schon komplett am Limit. Und
dazu kommt, dass MotionEye keine Objekterkennung hat. Also sprich, du kannst zwar versuchen
zu erkennen, ob sich was im Bild bewegt, aber du hast keine Klassifizierung... Oh, das ist
ein Bug, sehe ich gerade. Das sollte eigentlich auch sein. Exzellent. Du hast keine Möglichkeit
zu klassifizieren, dass es eine Person im Bild ist. Was natürlich viel besser ist, wenn
du was hast, was erkennt oder versucht zu erkennen, was im Bild ist, dann hast du viel weniger
Fehlalarme. Also bei der normalen Bewegungserkennung... Ich habe MotionEye erst noch nicht ausprobiert,
aber ich denke mal, da ist das auch so. Bei der normalen Bewegungserkennung oder bei Billigkameras,
die Bewegungserkennung, die funktioniert halt nicht mit irgendwas Trainiertem oder mit irgendwie
einem Algorithmus, der versucht zu erkennen, was es ist, sondern die testen dann beispielsweise,
wie viel hat sich vom Bildinhalt verändert, machen vielleicht irgendwie mal ein invertiertes
Image, ein normales Image, gucken, wie viel sich da geändert hat. Deswegen hast du ja
auch das Problem, dass normale Kameras, wenn du die Kamera schwenkst, sofort erkennen Bewegungen
oder Personen oder was auch immer, obwohl es gar keine Personen sind.
Parimors, ja, gut, das müsstest du einfach mal ausprobieren, wie zuverlässig das Ganze
ist. Ich habe ja selbst noch keine Erfahrungswerte, außer das bei meiner einen Kamera im Hof.
Also das kann durchaus sein, dass das gut funktioniert. Ich weiß es nicht. Dafür habe
ich es noch wie kein Langzeit-Dings. Du siehst, wie hier funktioniert es äußerst zuverlässig
in diesem einen Ausschnitt, in diesem Clip. Der erkennt jedes Mal mehrfach, wenn die Person
durchs Bild läuft. Und sollten sich die Verhältnisse bei der Kamera nicht ändern, wird das auch
weiter erkennen, auch bei Live-Aufnahmen funktioniert ja. Dazu kommt eine Sache, Parimors, die dir
wahrscheinlich gefallen wird, wenn du was aufnimmst. Guck mal, es ist egal, ob du jetzt selbst
was aufnimmst per Knopfdruck oder ob die Motion-Erkennung was aufnimmt, das ist egal. Guck mal, ich nehme
jetzt auf. Eins, zwei, drei Sekunden. So, guck ich mir die Aufnahme an. Wirst du feststellen,
achso, ok, ich habe nur zwei Sekunden aufgenommen. Aber du wirst feststellen. Eins, zwei, drei,
vier, fünf, sechs, sieben, acht, neun, zehn, elf, zwölf. Ok, zwölf. Die Aufnahme ist
zwölf Sekunden lang, obwohl ich nur zwei Sekunden auf Aufnahme gedrückt habe. Das liegt daran,
weil das immer einen Buffer hat von den letzten zehn Sekunden. Also sprich, wenn der DHL-Mann
durchs Bild läuft und die Kamera dann angeht und aufnimmt, nimmt es immer rückwirkend
die letzten zehn Sekunden noch mit auf. Das ist eigentlich ganz nützlich, weil normalerweise
hast du oftmals, also man hat ja oftmals das Problem, wenn die Motion-Erkennung angeht
und es anfängt aufzunehmen, dann ist die Sache, die man aufnehmen will, eigentlich
schon vorbei. Und das kann dir da nicht passieren, weil du immer einen Buffer von zehn Sekunden
hast. Also sprich, wenn der auslöst, aha, Person drinnen nimmt auf, dann nimmt er ab
jetzt zehn Sekunden rückwärts auf. Das heißt, du siehst auch jedes Mal, wie die Person auch
ins Bild läuft. Das finde ich auch echt nice. Warum hast du überhaupt die Kamera im Hof?
Hast du Angst, dass der Q-Chat vorbeikommt? Nee, beim Q-Chat mache ich mir nicht so die
Gedanken, aber bei anderen Leuten mache ich mir da Gedanken. Aber ich habe zuletzt im
Stream erzählt, warum der einzige Grund, warum ich eine Kamera an der Tür habe, ist, dass
ich sie frühzeitig sehe, wenn mein Vater vorbeikommt. Das habe ich doch das letzte
Mal im Stream schon erzählt. Und das ist der einzige Grund, warum ich angefangen habe
mit der Kamerageschichte. Aha, warum? Die kurze Story davon ist, weil mein Vater sich
bei mir eigentlich aus Prinzip nur meldet, wenn er Geld braucht. Und ich insofern ganz
froh bin, dass wir nicht so viel miteinander zu tun haben in letzter Zeit und das soll
auch so bleiben. Deswegen habe ich eine Kamera am Start und wenn ich sehe, dass mein Vater
vor der Tür steht, dann mache ich Stealth Mode Activated und dann mache ich einfach mich
auf. Weil ansonsten versucht er mir wieder Geld aus den Rippen zu leihen. Ich habe euch
die Geschichte aus der Karibik erzählt. Also für alle, die nicht dabei waren, ich werde
zum Beispiel ganz kurz sagen, mein Vater hat mir mal eine Mail geschickt. Das ist
nicht schlimm, das ist im Prinzip schon immer so. Das schockt mich nicht mehr. Das
belastet mich auch nicht. Mein Vater hat mir eine Mail geschickt aus der Karibik. Er
war irgendwie in der Karibik. Er hat mir eine Mail geschickt. Er hat mir eine Mail
geschrieben, er wurde entführt. Erst mal denke ich mir, was ist da los? Kam mir schon
von Anfang an recht merkwürdig vor. Zumal er auch gesagt hat, die deutsche Botschaft
interessiert sich nicht dafür. Da habe ich mir gedacht, was sind das für Entführer,
die ihm E-Mails schreiben lassen und mit der Botschaft telefonieren lassen und was auch
immer. Zumindest lange Rede, kurzer Sinn, was rausgekommen ist am Ende. Am Ende kam
raus, der wollte von mir 500 Euro haben, die ich ihm aber auch gegeben habe. Ich meine,
was würdet ihr machen, wenn sich der Vater bei euch meldet und sagt, hier mein Sohn,
ich wurde entführt, ich brauche Geld. So, dann habe ich mir gedacht, okay, 500 Euro,
was auch immer es ist, ich gebe dir jetzt erstmal 500 Euro, danach können wir weitergucken.
So, dann wisst ihr, was es war, was am Ende rausgekommen ist. Am Ende ist rausgekommen,
der war in der Karibik, das ist richtig, und der war im Krankenhaus in der Karibik.
Und der wollte abhauen, ohne zu bezahlen. Und dann haben die gesagt, ne, ne, ne, ne,
sie bleiben mal schön hier, bis ihre Rechnung bezahlt ist. Das war, der wurde nicht entführt,
der hat sich das einfach nur ausgedacht, dass ich ihm Geld gebe. Weil wenn der mir erzählt
hätte, ich bin ins Krankenhaus gegangen und wollte das Krankenhaus scammen, das war ja
eindeutig seine Absicht, der wollte ins Krankenhaus, sich da behandeln lassen und dann sich
verpissen, dann hätte ich ihm wahrscheinlich kein Geld gegeben. Hast du es zurückbekommen?
Nö, bis heute nicht. Jetzt, als hätte ich das zurückbekommen, Chat.
Ich will eben nicht, Alter. Oh, ich taub, ich taub meine Katze mit rein, was ist hier?
Das ist nicht die Katze, das ist ein Staubsauger. Also, das Geld, das Geld habe ich bis heute
nicht, das Geld habe ich bis heute nicht. Und so, das ist nicht die erste Aktion in
der Richtung. So, jetzt könnt ihr es vielleicht ein bisschen nachvollziehen, warum ich nicht
gerade so scharf drauf bin, wenn der vor der Tür steht. Doch, Ben, wahrscheinlich hätte
ich es ihm gegeben. Wahrscheinlich hätte ich es ihm auch gegeben. Wobei, wahrscheinlich,
doch, doch, ich gehe davon aus, ich hätte es ihm auch gegeben, aber ich hätte auf jeden
Fall mir das mal genauer überlegt, weil das ist nicht die erste Aktion in der Richtung.
Der denkt sich immer so Dinge aus und Funken Wahrheit ist bei den Storys immer dabei,
aber so das große Ganze stimmt halt nicht.
Ne, Preacher, viel besser ist die Tür erst gar nicht aufmachen. So, und deswegen habe
ich hier eine Kamera am Start, dann sehe ich, wenn der vor der Tür steht. Aha, ist mein
Vater, ich bin nicht da. Easy. Ganz einfach. Da muss ich mich da gar nicht damit auseinandersetzen.
So, und mein Vater war der einzige Grund, warum ich überhaupt die erste Kamera bei mir
hier im Haus installiert habe. Mittlerweile habe ich noch viel mehr, weil ich festgestellt
habe, Überwachungskameras sind äußerst, aber das war der ursprüngliche Anlass, warum
ich Überwachungskameras habe. Übrigens, das mit Gesichtserkennung ist durchaus möglich
damit, aber da müsste man auch ein bisschen mehr basteln. Das würde funktionieren, aber
nicht mehr auf dem Raspberry Pi. Die Sache ist die, das ist ja auch darauf ausgelegt,
dass es auf dem Raspberry Pi laufen kann, was auch geht, was auch ganz gut eigentlich
funktioniert. Natürlich jetzt nicht mit 10 Kameras und Erkennung, das überlastet zum
Raspberry Pi. Also Kameras kannst du massig hinzufügen, aber Bewegungserkennung kannst
du nicht so viele machen. Aber spätestens wenn du Face Recognition und sowas machen
willst, das ist dann ein bisschen schwierig in annähernd Echtzeit auf dem Raspberry Pi
zu machen. Bist du Vollzeit Streamer? Ne, ne, ne bin ich nicht. Ich glaube man könnte
mit 180, 200 Leuten im Durchschnitt als Vollzeit Streamer auch gar nicht überleben, es sei
denn, man hat noch einen OnlyFan Account, den die Leute kaufen wollen. Hab ich nicht,
deswegen kann ich kein Vollzeit Streamer sein. So, aber jetzt kommen wir zur eigentlichen
Sache, die wir heute machen wollen. Genau, also ich habe euch gezeigt wie das alles funktioniert
und mit Battlefield Gameplay funktioniert auch. Wunderbar. Jetzt zeige ich euch mal dieses
rückwirkend. Geht auf dem Raspberry Pi möglicher, was mittlerweile Möglichkeit zur GPU-Besteunigung?
Es geht die ganze Zeit schon auf dem Raspberry Pi, dass zum Beispiel Videos decoden lässt
von der GPU. Das gibt schon ganz lange. Das gibt schon eine ganze Weile. Warum ist das
Battlefield Video übrigens gerade MonkaS abgekackt? Alter, das Battlefield Video ist
ja mal voll am abscheißen. Das hier sind alles geskippte Frames. Warum? Ok, das Battlefield
Video ist gerade voll am abkacken. Das liegt übrigens nicht an der Software, das liegt
an diesem RTSP Server. Der RTSP Server ist mega Sack. Sobald ich da mehr als ein Video
starte, lokal, ist der am rumspacken. Ich weiß nicht warum. Starten wir das Ganze nochmal
und gucken, ob es jetzt funktioniert. Ah, da ist es wieder. Ok. So, Chat, passt mal
auf, ich zeige euch dieses rückwärts Aufnehmen. Merkt euch mal die Stelle hier. So, ich gucke
gerade gegen die Wand. So, ich habe jetzt nur eine Sekunde aufgenommen, wo ich gegen
die Wand gucke. So, und jetzt gucken wir uns die Aufnahme mal an. Und ihr seht, ah fuck,
dieses Video ist halt kaputt vom Battlefield Video. Und ihr seht, ich habe jetzt noch drauf,
wie ich zu dieser Wand hinlaufe, den Gegner kille und jetzt hier, seht ihr, 10 Sekunden
rückwirkend hat er aufgenommen. Inklusive die eine Sekunde. Das ist halt echt ein nice
feature, ne? Das ist richtig nice, ne? So, ok, und jetzt fangen wir mal an. Wir machen
noch einen anderen Test Stream rein. Wir machen nochmal den lokalen Stream rein. Wobei, ja,
doch. Pack W2. So, und jetzt können wir ein bisschen sortieren. Also, wie gesagt, Gesichtserkennung
ist hier recht einfach einzubauen. Aber, wobei, ich glaube, Dudes kann keine Gesichtserkennung,
oder? Kann das Face? Ne. Aber Diebstärk kann's. Ok, Face Detection. Also, man könnte damit
sogar Face-Erkennung bauen, aber das ist halt nichts, was man auf dem Raspberry Pi laufen
kann ordentlich. Braucht zu viel Leistung. Ok, sehr gut. Exzellent. Der hat echt Schmerzen
hier. Wegen dem, muss ich noch mal ausmachen. Der RTSP-Server, der ist total am abscheißen,
wenn ich mehr als einen Stream laufen habe. Und ich weiß nicht warum. Keine Ahnung. Aber,
mit Kameras hat er das Problem nicht. Nur mit dem lokalen RTSP-Server. Gibt es ein Limit,
bis wieviel man vorher aufnehmen kann? Aktuell sind es 10 Sekunden Hardcoded. Aber ansonsten,
du kannst das machen, bis was deine Festplatte hergibt. Du kannst das hier einstellen. Also,
aktuell, die Falls sind 10 Sekunden. Kannst das hier einstellen. Kannst sagen, zack. Keine
Ahnung. Hier. Kannst Timeshift einstellen. Also, kannst auch sagen 100 Sekunden. Die 10
Sekunden. Ach ja, Matt. Der Matt hat es durchschaut. Hab ich selbst gar nicht dran gedacht. Die
10 Sekunden buffert er im RAM. Das heißt, doch nicht soviel die Festplatte hergibt, sondern
soviel der RAM hergibt. Aber 10 Sekunden in H.264 ist nicht viel. Es sei denn, es ist
eine 4K, 150 FPS Kamera oder so. Dann soll ich vielleicht noch die Option einbauen,
dass man es auch auf der Festplatte buffern kann. Warum wäre Festplatte krass? Wäre
Festplatte nicht eigentlich besser? Solange es keine Micro SD-Karte ist. Micro SD-Karte
wäre dann halt kaputt. Dann wird auf 24x7 auf die Platte geschrieben. Ja, gut, das ist
jetzt nicht das Problem bei einer normalen Platte. Aber beim Raspberry Pi wird es mir
da Gedanken machen. Genau. Also, wir fangen jetzt mal an, das zu machen, was wir eigentlich
machen wollen. Also, wie gesagt, was ich einbauen will, ist eine Möglichkeit, dass ich die
Kamera Streams verschieben kann. Also von das zu das. Wir fügen noch mal ein hinzu. Ach
ja, und dass ich den Button einbaue, dass ich Kameras hinzufügen kann, ohne immer Setup
oben eingeben zu müssen. Das ist mein echter Hof. Aber nur ein Ausschnitt von meinem echten
Hof. So ein 15 Sekunden Ausschnitt, wo gerade jemand vorbeigelaufen ist, dass ich die Bewegungserkennung
und die Object Detection testen kann. Hof liegt. Kappa. Excellent Joke. Huge. Also mit dem
Battlefield-Video hat er so ein paar Schmerzen hier unten. Gut, aber das ignorieren wir jetzt
einfach mal. Wir versuchen jetzt mal einzubauen, dass man die Sachen rumschieben kann. Also,
lass mal überlegen. Wir fangen mit der einfachsten Geschichte an. Dieser Button da oben, also
der Add Camera-Button, den können wir ja standardmäßig einblenden. Also ich versuche mal zu erklären,
wie ich mir das vorgestellt habe, was wir machen können. Und zwar aktuell ist es ja
so, dass ich hier 500 Millisekunden draufdrücke mit der Maus oder mit dem Finger. Ich habe
das halt so gemacht, dass es eben auch touchmäßig sich gut bedienen lässt. Dann kriege ich
so ein Menü. So, und was ich in dem Menü machen kann ist, ich kann mir die Aufnahmen angucken
von der jeweiligen Kamera. Oder ich kann Kamera aufnehmen, Aufnahmen starten, stoppen. Oder
ich kann in die Settings von der Kamera. So, die zwei Sachen gibt es. Oh, die drei Sachen
gibt es. So, was man jetzt machen könnte, was ich mir überlegt habe ist, der Wett-Trust
ist acht Monate am Start. Dankeschön für den Sub. Ist gar nicht Prime, ist richtig echt
hier. Dankeschön. Nimm doch statt dem Battlefield Stream eine Videoaufnahme aus einer Stadt,
wo Menschenerkennbar sind. Haben wir, haben wir, wir haben diesen komischen Pokemon Stream.
Wenn ich den finde, war es Plup3. Ja, das ist der Pokemon Stream. Der, den machen wir jetzt.
Jetzt müssen wir erstmal warten, bis der reconnected ist. Der droppt aber ganz schön viele Streams,
ganz schön viele FPS. Die Stadt ist gerade nochmal neu. Hab ich da irgendwas verkehrt
zu machen? Hab ich gerade gesagt, was? Achso. Ah, da ist er. Okay. Da, da, da können wir
jetzt Objekterkennung anmachen. Alles klar. Moment. Das ist so kacke das, Alter. Diese
RTSP-Server ist so schlecht. Der kackt immer ab, wenn man mehr als einen Stream macht.
Wie gesagt, das liegt nicht an mir, das liegt an diesem Kack. Ich weiß nicht, ob es dann
was anderes besseres gibt. Wir haben übrigens richtig Big Brain Musik hier im Hintergrund
zu starten. Kann die KI Fahrzeugkennzeichen erkennen? Nein. So, starten wir mal nur ein.
Person, Person, Person. Da kommt er nicht mit. Das ist zu viel, das ist zu viel und zu schnell.
Alles, alles Person hier, Leute, alles Person. Das ist zu viel auf einmal. Aber immerhin,
er erkennt schon, dass da Persons drauf sind. Ach, hier erkennt er übrigens jetzt einen
Truck oder irgendwie sowas gleich. Er kennt auch, dass es eine Gruppe von Leuten ist und
einzelne Leute und so. Und das Ganze ohne großartig CPU-Lass zu machen. Also er macht
es ja nur alle zwei Sekunden. Truck? Ach nee, das habe ich ausgeplannet. Früher hat er
noch den Truck hier erkannt. So, mal gucken, ob ich jetzt das andere wieder einschalten
kann, ohne dass er komplett wieder eskaliert. Ok, aktuell funktioniert jetzt noch alles.
Excellent. Müsste für die obersten Cam nicht mehrere Aufnahmen da sein. Das habe ich
ausgeschaltet. Das kann man hier einschalten. Du kannst in die Settings gehen. In die Settings
für die Object Detection und kannst sagen, du willst aufnehmen oder nicht aufnehmen.
Auch wenn da steht, er nimmt, er würde aufnehmen, er nimmt gerade nicht auf. Also das habe ich
gerade standardmäßig aus, weil ansonsten hätte ich beim Testen die komplette Festplatte
voll mit Videoaufnahmen. Das ist nicht Sinn und Zweck der Sache. Diese RTSP-Server, da
macht mich fertig. Sobald man sich mehr als zwei, drei Mal connectet, kackt der Stream
ab. Total hängen gebliebener Crap. Und wie gesagt, mit echten Kameras passiert das nicht.
Das liegt rein an diesem lokalen RTSP-Server. Wie man jetzt ja auch sieht, jetzt geht es
nämlich wieder. Ok, also, sehr gut. Dann würde ich sagen, fangen wir mal an den Kram
einzubauen. Gehen wir mal Home. So, und dieser Button, der normalerweise nur angezeigt wird,
wenn keine Kameras drin sind, den werden wir jetzt einblenden, wenn jemand 1,5 Sekunden
drückt. Weil ich muss ja darauf achten, dass es touch-bedienbar ist. So, und ich habe mir
gedacht, wir machen das jetzt so. So, bei 500 Millisekunden bei so einem normalen Press
kommen halt die Options, wo ich Kamera anlegen, Kamera löschen, sonst was kann. Oder auch
Aufnahmen einblenden kann oder was auch immer. Und wenn man lang drückt, dann blende ich
so ein Optionsmenü ein. Also wenn man 1,5 Sekunden drückt, dann mache ich irgendwas.
Ich weiß noch nicht genau was, aber irgendwas werde ich schon machen. Kopieren wir uns das
mal. Ach nee, habe ich ja schon. Habe ich ja schon hier drin. Nur, dass es nichts macht,
oder? Testen wir mal, ob es funktioniert. Beim 5 Sekunden-Press werden die Geschütze
hochgefahren, Selbstschussanlage ist an, ja. So, also nach 1,5 Sekunden, zack, passt. Sehr
schön. So, dann setzen wir jetzt irgendwie sowas wie, keine Ahnung, wie können wir diese
Option nennen? Layout-Mode nennen wir das jetzt mal. Ports. So, und im Layout-Mode kann
ich Sachen rumschieben oder Kameras hinzufügen. Das klingt doch eigentlich ganz gut. This
Layout-Mode gleich, als wenn ich jetzt lange drauf drücke, dann geht der Layout-Modus
an. Und wenn der Layout-Modus an ist, dann blende ich den Button ein. So machen wir das.
Das klingt doch schon mal ganz sinnvoll. Sollte das nicht Auto-Completen? Habe ich
es auch Layout-Modus genannt? So, gucken wir mal, ob das funktioniert. 1,2,3,4,5. Eine
Buttons. Ok, stellen wir ihn einfach mal an. Ah, ah, oh. Da war er, habt ihr ihn gesehen.
Ich habe ihn genau gesehen, den Button. Das sollte aber nicht sein, das gefällt mir nicht,
dass der Button da unten ist. Ok, das liegt hier dran. Ich positioniere den Button nämlich
absolut in der Mitte der Seite. Ok, das ist doch schon besser. Center. Das ist doch schon
mal schöner. Jetzt müssen wir nur gucken, dass das Ding in die Mitte kommt. Also machen
wir mal ein extra Diff drum. Und verschieben mal dieses Show zum Diff. Und jetzt können
wir sagen irgendwie Text-Center. Jetzt soll es in der Mitte sein. Ja, wunderbar. So, dann
kriegt ihr jetzt noch eine Margin von 5. Ah, das sieht doch jetzt schon mal ganz brauchbar
aus. Also sprich, wenn ich den Layout-Modus, wenn ich lang presse, dann macht er das an
und ansonsten macht er das aus. Schon mal ganz praktisch. Funktioniert auch, wenn man
draufklickt. Ok. So, und jetzt muss ich irgendwie was basteln, mit dem ich die Videos hoch und
runter schieben kann. Ich probiere mal, ich probiere mal das erste, was mir einfällt.
Mal gucken, ob das ordentlich funktioniert. Wir machen nämlich einfach einen Button oben
und unten drunter. Und den Button machen wir dann so breit wie die ganze Seite und dann
kann man dann hoch und runter schieben. Dazu brauchen wir jetzt erstmal ein ordentliches
Icon. Einen schönen Pfeil hoch, Pfeil runter button, Icon. Die Seite laggt übrigens immer
so krass rum. Was nehmen wir denn? Was taugt denn? Der da? Arrow Thick. Excellent. Fat Arrow.
Den nehmen wir. Arrow. Arrow Up. Thick. Alter, die Anomusik, der tut hier gerade als ist
hier World First Boss Clear gerade im Stream angesagt. Ok, also machen wir mal einen Button
oben drüber. Die Anomusik ist mir gerade so anstrengend. Ja, ein bisschen doodle. So,
ehm. Ok, wir haben einen Button oben drüber, schon mal gut. Nee, V-Icon. Ok. Jetzt haben
wir einen Button oben drüber, das ist doch schon mal ganz nice. Ich brauche noch einen
Button unten drunter. Schade, dass der Remastered verkackt wurde. Wurde der echt verkackt?
Ich kann sie überhaupt nicht einschätzen, weil ich habe es gar nicht gespielt. Ok,
das sieht jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen suboptimal aus, aber es geht schon mal in die richtige
Richtung. Probieren wir mal was aus. Style, Breite 100%. Ah, das sieht doch schon besser
aus. Kann man das direkt hier setzen? Ja, guck mal. Das sieht doch jetzt schon ganz brauchbar
aus. Guck mal. Pfeil hoch, Pfeil runter. So, jetzt machen wir da vielleicht noch ein bisschen
Abstand dazwischen. Margin unten, 5 Pixels. Ja. Das ist doch ganz gut. Ich meine, normaler
View ist, ah Moment, ich muss ja noch einstellen, dass der das nur anzeigt, wenn Layout Modus
ist. Reshow. Die Autoverfolgung geht nicht. Hä?
Ok. Exzellent. Das funktioniert schon mal. Ah? Das ist eigentlich ganz nice. Das ist
also, wenn man Longpress macht, kriege ich die ganzen Optionen hier eingeplant. Das ist
doch schon mal praktisch. Easy. Äh, der ist defaultmäßig true? Ah ja, passt ja auch.
Gut, alles klar. Also mal weiter im Text. Zerschrott RTSP Server. Ich mach's jetzt aus.
Was? Wir können den einfach mehrfach starten. Achso, kann man jetzt noch was anderes sagen?
Port oder so? Äh, ist das Minus Minus Port 8001? Ne. Try Minus Minus Help. Ich hab Minus Minus
hier, aber what the fuck? Alter, was ist das für Musik jetzt? Anele Style. Im Yammerfile
vermutlich. Ja, wow, ich will gerade Yammer editieren dafür. Na gut, da muss ich ihn ab
und zu mal refreshen, kann ich mitleben. So, ähm. Ok, hoch und runter passiert noch nichts,
aber das sieht jetzt schon mal ganz brauchbar aus. Jetzt probier ich noch mal andere Sachen
aus, irgendwie, dass man hier unten diesen Rand wegkriegt. Weiß nicht, ob wir irgendwelche
CSS-Leute mit CSS-Durchblick haben. Man kann glaube ich jetzt sowas sagen, wie hier Display
Inline oder sowas, dann sollte da, hm. Jetzt eigentlich vermute, dass der Rand weggeht.
Was gibt's denn da noch so? Block? Nein. Äh. Äh, wie krieg ich diesen Kar-Krant da unten
weg? Gibt's noch? Block? Flex? Ah, yes, Flex, alles klar, war's full? Ne, full gibt's
nicht, Flex. Warum geht das jetzt? Ich hab keinen Plan, was ich da gemacht hab, versteht
das irgendjemand? Ne, none ist weg, dann ist es weg. Ja. Padding null. Kann ich auch mal
probieren. Ne. Display Flex. Ich hab keine Ahnung, was das tut, aber es funktioniert,
das reicht mir schon. Es ist genug, reicht. So, Flex. Okay. Ich ignorier jetzt einfach
mal, ob das Video läuft oder nicht. Warum benutzt du eigentlich View und nicht React
cooler? Ganz einfach, äh, weil ich die anderen zwei nicht kann und View kann ich halbwegs.
Muss React lernen, Zetke. Wieso das ist nicht Zetke? React ist das mit Abstand größte
Frontend-Framework überhaupt. Außer, außer, jQuery. War das nicht March in Padding? Kann
auch sein. Also wenn's nach der Größe geht von verbreiteten Frontend-Frameworks, müsstest
du jQuery, äh, jQuery lernen. Aber niemand, der noch mal verstanden ist, würde wahrscheinlich
zwei, will ich heute sagen, jawoll. jQuery, beste und, äh, ich lerne nix anderes mehr.
Ich glaube, prinzipiell zu wissen, wie jQuery funktioniert, ist nicht verkehrt, aber, so
rein mit jQuery kommst du halt auch nicht weit, weil selbst Bootstrap ist mittlerweile jQuery
frei. Okay, also jetzt haben wir den Kram eingeplant. Wir können Button hoch machen, Button runter.
Okay
So weit so gut das heißt wenn wir jetzt button hochdrücken
JQuery war zur damaligen zeit poggers ja
Damals hattest du ja auch die meisten sachen im browser noch nicht drinnen vor allem heute hast du ja sowas wie hier
Query selektor hat es ja damals alles gar nicht das ist ja schon zum größten teil fast wie jQuery
So also wenn man den button nach unten drückt
Also wenn man den button nach unten drückt da war in keinem move daun
Und wenn man den button nach oben klickt
So nur noch mal kurz überlegen wie man den kram am besten jetzt programmiert das funktioniert
Okay wir fangen mal einfach an
Wenn ich den hier daunen
Er ist sehr gut wenn ich den hier daunen drücke dann geht dann dann ich mache einfach nur mal
Hardcoded das oberste element eins runter
Wie sieht das ganze im fullscreen aus so wie man sich vorstellt
So sieht das im fullscreen aus
Seitenverhältnis bleibt und die buttons werden ein bisschen größer
Was du dir an und schaust wir basteln an der videoüberwachungs software weiter
Guck der erkennt sogar wenn leute durch bild laufen
So also button hoch button runter wir fangen mal mit wir fangen mal mit button mit move down an
Und daunen
Ab
Okay wie fangt man da jetzt am besten an also
Um sachen
Okay also ich habe hier mein camera array in dem will ich wahrscheinlich erstmal nix rum sortieren würde ich mal vermuten
Okay um zu gucken ob es funktioniert werden wir das ganze jetzt mal hardcoden und schauen ob es funktioniert ob es prinzipiell geht
Wir vertauschen jetzt mal erstes und zweites element und gucken ob das ob das klappt
Wenn man hier draufklickt
Okay also erst wir einfach nur mal gucken ob es an sich funktionieren würde
So jetzt müssen wir sagen set oder weiß ich aus dem kopf die sonntags nicht aber hier oben haben wir es doch drinstehen
Das cameras das ist der index also null auf index null kommt das zweite
Und auf index eins kommt das erst also sprich wir vertauschen einfach die ersten zwei elemente
Mal gucken ob das jetzt funktioniert also wenn das jetzt klappt sollte das da unten gehen das nach oben easy funktioniert
Oder loading balken geht nicht mit naja gut das ist zu verschmerzen
Okay
Und wenn ich jetzt wieder drauf drück aber vertauscht der immer erstes und zweites okay
Also das okay prinzipiell funktioniert es schon mal so wie ich mir das gedacht habe jetzt sollte man nur noch gucken dass es halt dynamisch wird
Vielleicht sollte man später noch bei den ersten leiten
Vielleicht sollte man später noch bei dem untersten und obersten den äußeren backen entfernen das eine gute idee
Weil das oberste kann man ja nicht hoch machen
Das können wir sogar relativ sollte man eigentlich glaube ich relativ einfach
verwerkstelligen können
Und
Und und wir machen das jetzt mal beim oberen da ist es nämlich glaube ich einfacher und
I und gleich null zack schon ist er weg und hier sagen wir schau
Aller big brain musik am start und hier sagen wir und
I und gleich nicht so was machen
Ach so ich muss hier unten ja gucken alles auch weg guck mal easy funktioniert
Schon schon sind die buttons weg um und unten
Ist es eine gute idee gewesen finde ich nice
Ok und das vertauschen geht immer noch
Ah ok gut dass sie backt übrigens also mit dem laden checkte irgendwie nicht so genau aber das ist jetzt nicht so wild
Ok so und jetzt müssen wir irgendwie dafür sorgen dass das nicht nur mit dem ersten und zweiten zu vertauschen funktioniert sondern dass das dynamisch
immer funktioniert
So das heißt von der idee her
Überlegen
Also von der idee her brauchen wir jetzt erstmal was wo wir unsere layout speichern können die musik das ist richtig
Ich sagte hab ich da wird das gehirn größer von
Irgendwie layout
Ok also ich will ja nicht direkt an den kameras rumwürsten weil das update sich ja immer automatisch
Ok also machen wir erstmal machen wir erstmal eine kopie von den kameras
Kopie von den kameras machen
Kannst doch den index im array holen den an benutzen jaja sowas in der richtung habe ich mir jetzt auch gerade überlegt
Wir müssen nur gucken dass wir in dem in dem camera array nicht nicht
selbst rumwürsten weil das wird regelmäßig überschrieben wenn sich kameras updaten
Ok guck mal jetzt einfach mal
Genau if
Layout wenn layout nicht mehr ist
Genau if layout wenn layout null ist dann muss ich es mir aus den kameras da holen
So mal schauen ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher wie das am ende aussehen wird
So also wir kopieren uns mal die das camera array dass man da jetzt nicht drin rumwürsten muss
So
Plett mir den kram ein dass ich ein bisschen debug ausgaben machen kann
So also ich kopiere mir einmal alle kameras dann suche ich mit dem index raus
Von der aktuellen camera also das irgendwie index
index index oft glaube ist das
index oft alle die musik ist ja gut anno jetzt so kann ich nicht bei nachdenken
bonkers
Das ist mir zu aggressive alter was passiert denn beiutil manager. milestone
Academy für ju alles klar
Es hört sich, wisst ihr, es hört fast an wie irgendein Splatoon.
Okay, was ist Big Brain Academy für ein Game gewesen?
Alles klar, das ist eines dieser 30.000 Gehirn-Chogging-Games für den DS, oder?
Brain Power, was?
Music for Brain Power, Mozart Musik for Brain Power, exquisite, alles klar, ah, yes, wächst
euch auch schon, spürt ihr es Leute, wächst das Gehirn, alles klar, jetzt brauchen wir
noch den passenden 500-jährigen Rotwein, ah, yes, alles klar, so ist gut, du bist 4-Head
geworden, das heißt du hast downgraded von 5-Head, ne, also Mozart brauch ich jetzt nicht
dabei, Brain Power, ne, MonkaS, man darf ja auf Twitch keine random Musik mehr anmachen,
do the study music alpha waves, what the fuck ist das?
Also da kriege ich, da kriege ich kein größeres Gehirn davon, das geht mir auf den Keks,
ne, okay wir machen was anderes, happy Kirby music, viel besser, ah, yes, davon kriege
ich auch mehr Brain, wer sucht auch in YouTube nach Brain Power, der Chat, der Chat hat gesagt,
ich soll auf YouTube nach Brain Power suchen, und ich hab mir gedacht, ich weiß zwar eigentlich
schon, dass es blöd ist, aber ich mach mal das was der Chat sagt, und siehste, das ist
rausgekommen, exzellent, okay also schauen wir mal, ich brauch noch was anderes Leute,
also nur mal so von den Ideen, was ich mir jetzt denke ist, also es gibt zwei Varianten,
entweder ich lade die Seite zum ersten Mal, und ich zeig einfach die Streams an in der
Reihenfolge, wie sie angelegt sind, oder es gibt einen Layout, und ich zeig dieses
gespeicherte Layout an, so die zwei Sachen gibts, das heißt ich muss jetzt erstmal dynamisch
berechnen was Sache ist, also sprich einfach nur Kameras oder Layout anzeigen, das machen
wir hier mal, wir lassen es automatisch von View berechnen, was gerade angesagt ist, nämlich
wenn das Layout gesetzt ist, wenn das nicht gesetzt ist, dann will ich die Kameras haben,
Ups, das ist falsch was ich hier mache, das geht doch irgendwie anders, so klar, so, ah
yes, exzellent, so, dann können wir das nämlich austauschen schon mal hier oben, gehen wir
nicht über alle Kameras, sondern über alle Kameras, oder alle Layouts, okay, alles klar,
das ergibt schon mal Sinn, und ansonsten return die Layouts, moin, lila, regen, bogen, einhorn,
pony, ah yes, exzellent, okay das lassen wir jetzt erstmal so, so, wir probieren jetzt
erstmal die Sachen mit move down aus, also, da können wir das mit dem Layout weglassen,
so, index, wenn er das findet, wenn ich da drauf klicke, gucken wir mal ob er den index
findet, er sollte jetzt ja eigentlich sagen index 0, okay, das funktioniert, so sieht
es aus ja, also der erste Teil ist richtig, okay das ist index 0, so das heißt, wenn ich
das Ding gefunden habe, und das ist index 0, dann will ich, also ist egal, ich will immer
index plus 1 machen, das heißt ich lösche das jetzt erstmal, slice, war das slice, array,
delete, element, js, google, beste, how can i remove a specific item, exzakt, das brauchen
wir immer, splice, nicht slice, warum java script, wo, also was haben die sich schon wieder
dabei gedacht, warum heißt das nicht einfach remove oder delete oder delete if oder delete
element oder irgendwas, warum heißt das splice, niemand denkt daran, wenn ich eine spezifische
Sache erdenkst, er remove, jetzt ein splice, aber java script leute sind einfach so krass
big brain, das ist, da können wir als normalsterbliche einfach nicht mithalten, also was muss ich
tun, splice und dann index und dann 1, so das heißt jetzt habe ich es entfernt, weil du
spice in higher order functions verwenden kannst, yes, sehr, der chat ist, die musik
ist eindeutig ins gehirn vom chat gegangen, aber man könnte ja auch sowas wie remove rein
machen und splice, ok, also jetzt habe ich es entfernt, ok, jetzt habe ich es entfernt,
jetzt muss ich den kram irgendwie wieder hinzufügen, ok, also wieder splice und wie fügt man jetzt
was hinzu, splice add item index, auto insert, stack overflow, leute ich sag's euch immer
wieder, auch leute die im chat fragen, 80% stack overflow, splice index 0, ach deleting
zero items at first, das ist wirklich big brain function hier, splice also aber index
plus 1, nichts löschen vorher und dann inserten, moment das ist falsch rum, was mache ich denn,
ist falsch rum, ok, das funktioniert jetzt, this layout gleich, mal gucken ob das jetzt
funktioniert, es geht, moment, das geht, das geht, einfach so, hätte ich jetzt nicht gedacht
dass es einfach funktioniert, guck mal, zack, einfach nach unten moveen, zack und jetzt
den hier, zack und den hier, zack, jetzt ist der oben, jetzt geht er wieder unten, easy,
sehr gut, korgas, richtig korgas, so ok, das heißt wir machen jetzt den umgedrehten Teil,
wunderbar, genug gefreut, so wir machen jetzt den umgedrehten Teil move up, da machen wir
das gleich, ok, das können wir jetzt prinzipiell, wahrscheinlich können wir das einfach kopieren
und ein paar Sachen anpassen, index will ich weiter, so index und jetzt index, ne das passt
immer noch, ich will immer noch das item, wie man sich freut, ja ich hätte das nicht
damit gerechnet, also das passt ja immer noch, ich will immer noch das item löschen, so
und jetzt will ich es hinzufügen, index minus eins, sehe ich das richtig, die Frage ist
nur was passiert, wenn der index schon null ist, kann er nicht passieren, weil wir den
button ausgeblendet haben, ok, also wir würden es kaputt machen, würden wir auf den button
hier oben klicken, aber der button ist weg und weil der button weg ist und der button
critical information leckt, kann er gar nichts passieren, sehr gut, das heißt kann ich jetzt
nach oben, guck mal ich kann jetzt nach oben move easy, guck mal zack, zack, zack, funktioniert,
dazu kann ich nur sagen, das ist ja mal richtig, also wunderbar, finde ich gut, finde ich gut,
übrigens Leute, ich mach das mal kurz aus hier, guck mal ob es dann wieder tut, die
Kirby Musik hat geholfen, guck jetzt kann ich das einfach nach oben, ja ok das leckt
ein bisschen hinterher mit der Erkennung, aber das ist in Ordnung, guck mal, ja bis zum nächsten
Redraw leckt das hinterher, das lässt sich alles noch fixen, funktioniert, nice, so jetzt
müssen wir nur noch dafür sorgen, dass der Kram gespeichert wird, weil guck mal ich schiebe
das jetzt hoch und wenn ich reloade, dann ist es wieder unten, das heißt ich brauche
irgendwie Local Storage oder sowas wo ich das drin speichere, also machen wir an der
Stelle noch sowas hier, Local Storage, Set, Layout, Jason, Stringify und zwar Layout,
das machen wir hier oben auch noch, so jetzt wird das ganze gespeichert und jetzt müssen
wir noch dafür sorgen, dass es geladen wird, das Layout jedes mal wenn ich die Seite aufmache,
also jedes mal wenn ich die Seite aufmache, wollen wir das Layout laden, also Local Storage,
was hat das noch hier alles, Get Item, Layout, da müssen wir jetzt erstmal schauen ob das
überhaupt gesetzt ist, weil das erste mal wo ich die Seite aufmache, das erste mal wo
ich die Seite aufmache gibt es ja noch kein Layout, du sprichst Stringify genauso aus
wie ich, ich spreche Sachen gerne so aus, ich sag ja auch Stream absichtlich, this Layout
is Jason Pass Result, so jetzt schauen wir mal, jetzt schiebe ich das hoch und reloade
und jetzt sollte das oben bleiben, hä funktioniert, easy, du Leute ich glaub dir, ich glaub das
war es schon oder, guck mal das funktioniert jetzt, also so sieht es standardmäßig aus,
dann mache ich diesen Layout Modus an, dann kann ich neue Kameras hinzufügen und jetzt
kann ich einfach Sachen moveen, easy, guck mal einfach moveen, funktioniert, also entweder
stehe ich jetzt aufm Schlauch oder das war es wirklich, ich wusste nichts mehr, es funktioniert
jetzt einfach, ah ne ne ne so einfach ist es nicht, doch ich hab was vergessen, was
passiert denn jetzt wenn ich Kameras hinzufüge oder entferne, das funktioniert bestimmt noch
nicht, weil wenn ich jetzt, ha ne das wird nicht funktionieren, weil ich hab jetzt gespeichert
dass ich diese Kameras hab, so und jetzt pass mal auf ich lösche jetzt mal was, ich lösche
die jetzt mal hier, ja, lull, guck mal, ok das hat er nicht gecheckt, der denkt immer
noch die gibt es, weil ich wo ich das letzte Mal das Layout gespeichert hab, gab es die
Kamera ja noch, ja das heißt ich muss jetzt gucken, oh das wird jetzt ein bisschen eklig,
da fällt mir jetzt gar nichts so gutes dazu ein, ok wir filtern das einfach hier, also
if, ist wahrscheinlich nicht die beste Variante, du müsstest glaube ich beide synchronisieren,
ich kann einfach jedes mal, nachdem eine Kamera gelöscht wurde nochmal das Layout speichern,
ja das könnte ich machen, da müsste ich aber irgendwie noch ein Event basteln, dass
man mitbekommt, wobei nee müsste ich nicht, ich bekomme doch jedes mal hier eine Nachricht
geschickt, ich hab doch hier eine CraftQL Subscription, ich bekomme doch jedes mal eine
Nachricht geschickt, was ist mit anderen Clients die gerade nicht offen sind, ja deswegen ist
eigentlich doch besser wenn wir es so machen wie ich mir das gedacht hab, also sprich jedes
mal, wartet mal ich hab irgendwas im Hals, jedes mal wenn die Seite geladen wird, oder
diese Startseite geladen wird, gucke ich einfach nach, ob es Kameras gibt die ich im Layout
habe, und dann schmeiße ich sie raus, oder umgedreht Kameras die ich nicht drin hab,
dann nehme ich sie rein und hängen sie unten an, das dürfte wahrscheinlich die einfachere
Anzahl sein, ok also gucken wir ob die Kameras gesetzt sind, wo kommt denn das daher, also
wenn die Kameras ungleich Null sind, so dann machen wir eine Schleife über die ganzen
Kameras, so und jetzt gucken wir ob die Kamera, oh na das ist aber eklig, aber erstmal gucken
dass die Funktion funktioniert, so das heißt wenn die Kamera nicht in Layouts drin ist,
dann wurde sie hinzugefügt, das ist jetzt allerdings nicht das was wir fixen wollen,
sondern wir haben hier eine Kamera gelöscht, das heißt wir machen jetzt erstmal das zuerst,
wenn wir eine Kamera gelöscht haben, also Kamera gelöscht, dann sagen wir mal, ok ich
habe eine Idee, also wir filtern einfach raus, wir filtern das einfach raus, wir gucken jetzt
einfach, gibt es die Kamera die ich gespeichert habe, gibt es die überhaupt noch, das ist
halt schon eklig oder, das ist schon ganz schön abartig, sowas in der Richtung, ah
yes exquisite und geht das jetzt, hey funktioniert, ok an Schönheit kaum zu überbieten, so und
jetzt machen wir das ganze noch für wenn Kameras hinzugefügt werden, also if, so und jetzt
gucke ich ob im Layout irgendeine Kamera, alter das ist ja voll abartig, da muss ich
was anderes für einfallen lassen, ah nee not, ok das ist alles andere als schön, aber
das sollte funktionieren, danach das Layout speichern, nee ich muss das Layout nicht speichern,
das macht er jedesmal dynamisch wenn ich die Seite neu lade und erst wenn ich das nächste
Mal editiere dann speichert er, das ist glaube ich ok, ok das testen wir jetzt mal ob das
funktioniert, ok also add camera, cacv, machen wir nochmal den da unten als Teststream rein,
so da sollte es jetzt eigentlich unten anhängen, ah Funst, Leute Funst, funktioniert hat es
unten angehängt, ok jetzt probieren wir es nochmal mit löschen, was löschen wir jetzt
mal, wir löschen den zweiten, den zweiten löschen wir, also sprich der da sollte jetzt
verschwinden, delete ok, hat funktioniert, eben waren es noch zwei, ok jetzt löschen
wir den unteren, wie es einfach funktioniert, einfach klappt, ah ok das funktioniert aber
noch nicht, wobei das ist nicht schlimm das kann bis zum Refresh warten oder, das bekomme
ich natürlich nicht mit wenn ich den local storage in eine modifiziere, ich glaube das
ist nicht wild, das geht dann halt bis zum Refresh, das ist ok da kann ich mit leben,
nice, das ist ja richtig gut, das gefällt mir, so und ich würde sagen jetzt ist mehr
oder weniger alles drin was ich einbauen wollte zumindest funktionell, also an manchen
Stellen ist es wirklich noch hardcore eklig, ich muss euch nochmal was zeigen was auch
richtig eklig gemacht ist, guck mal hier Controller, Kamera Controller, ja steht sogar oben drüber,
es buggt rum, weil es manchmal zu schnell reloadet bevor es entfernt wurde, deswegen
habe ich einfach sowas eingebaut, das ist nicht schön aber mir ist jetzt nichts besseres
eingefallen auf den ersten Blick, einfach mal drei Sekunden warten fertig, in Wirklichkeit
geht auch das Kamera hinzufügen viel schneller, aber ich wollte sicher gehen dass die alte
Kamera auf jeden Fall gestoppt ist vorher, so nachdem ich das Kamera stopp so low-prane
mäßig programmiert habe, dass ich nicht darauf warten kann bis es gestoppt ist, mache
ich immer einfach so, ja Leute ich bin begeistert, es funktioniert, es funktioniert, exquisite,
es klappt einfach, so jetzt müssen wir noch eine Sache machen, nämlich den müssen wir
standardmäßig, wo ist er hier auf falls stellen, weil ansonsten sieht er standardmäßig
kacke aus, so und dieses JavaScript Mobile Debug Ding muss ich rausschmeißen, das ist
irgendwo hier drinnen Main, ne wo ist das Public, ist fort, das Ding das ist übrigens
richtig nice, das ist ne JavaScript Konsole in JavaScript, also das ist quasi ne JavaScript
Developer Tools in JavaScript, da fragt man sich jetzt natürlich wozu braucht man das,
da sind wir wieder bei Safari, Safari auf dem iPhone hat keine Developer Tools, deswegen
das Ding geht halt auch auf Safari, so richtige Developer Tools hier gehen halt nicht Safari,
iOS, Safari Developer Tools gehen glaube ich nur, wenn man von dem Mac remote sich irgendwie
an den Safari im iOS Attached, genau, genau, genau was 3 zu schreibt, das ist halt bescheuert,
ja, übrigens Chat ich weiß falls da Sebaro da wäre, dem würde dieses Projekt ganz besonders
gut gefallen, weil die haben ein Logo, was da Sebaro sicherlich toll findet.
Wird jetzt wahrscheinlich bei jeder Webseite eingebaut, so save, dann ist das weg, gibt
es eigentlich einen Grund, wieso Apple nur Safari haben will, ja weil Safari von Apple
ist und Apple ja prinzipiell Sachen nicht mag, die nicht von ihnen sind, weil Apple
das ist der beste Begründung dafür, ja, ja Chat das war jetzt einfach, das hat einfach
funktioniert, ich würde sagen es funktioniert einfach, gut also lass mal kurz in uns gehen,
habe ich jetzt noch irgendwas vergessen, was man unbedingt braucht, also man kann, man
kann Sachen moveen, man kann Sachen hinzufügen, man kann abbrechen, was ja, also ohne abbrechen
wäre doof, man kann Streams edit, man kann Kameras editieren, also ich könnte jetzt zum
Beispiel sagen, da oben soll jetzt nicht dieses Video drin sein, sondern dieses, andere Quelle,
das sollte eigentlich gehen, ja genau, man kann Bewegungserkennung an und aus machen,
man kann Aufnahme an und aus schalten, wie lange aufnehmen soll bei Bewegungserkennung
und wie lange rückwirkend aufnehmen soll, äh, warum, warum kriege ich hier oben sowas
angezeigt und da nicht, bestimmt, bestimmt falscher Typ, ah, type number und da unten
nicht type number, excellent, gibt es bei, beim Ender nicht noch Probleme, nö, aber
funktioniert, edit, oh das hat er nicht gespeichert, ups, addiert sich das, ja, ja genau, das addiert
sich, also sprich, es sind 10 Sekunden rückwirkend plus 30 Sekunden, genau, finish, ja das funktioniert
einfach, ne, aber, ne, guck mal, also das funktioniert mit dem Playout, oder was meinste,
was, was, hä, was, äh, müsste, was sollte kaputt gehen, mach jetzt mal da, ich mach
jetzt da mal, ähm, object-Erkennung an, oh das speichert er nicht, warum nicht, hab
ich irgendwas kaputt gemacht, ha, warum speichert er das nicht, oh, der speichert das schon,
der hat bloß nicht erkannt, ja, hat er grad ne Person erkannt, ok, excellent, oh, hat
er das jetzt nicht gespeichert, hm, mal kurz, Puckwasser drin stellen, ok, ok, ok, ok,
true, das müsste eigentlich da stehen, true, äh, warum zeigt er das Icon da oben nicht
an, der sollte da oben eigentlich den Icon anzeigen, dass Object-Erkennung an ist, hm,
warum nicht, warum macht er das nicht, hm, ich sehe schon, so ein paar Bugs hat's noch,
weil hier funktioniert das doch auch, wenn ich das an und aus schalte, ne, Moment, das
sollte nicht sein, ok, äh, ja, gut, das sollte nicht so sein, na gut, Person, alles klar,
also man sieht so mit so Cartoon-Dingern kommt die Person-Erkennung nicht so wirklich klar,
der denkt halt, das ist ne Person, ich mein, das ist halt ne dicke Person, hat gewisse
Ähnlichkeiten, ach, ich weiß woran das liegt, oh, das ist ja Low-Prain, da hab ich ja überhaupt
nicht dran gedacht, ich speichere mehr die, oh nee, da hab ich jetzt keinen Bock drauf,
da muss ich mir noch mal Gedanken zu machen in Ruhe, das Problem ist, ich speichere ja
hier das komplette, das komplette Kamera-Layout, also die kompletten Kamera-Objekte und dann
ändert sich ja nix mehr dran, oh, ok, wir machen das anders, ich speichere da nicht
die Kamera-Objekte, ich speichere einfach nur die Kamera-IDs, ich speichere einfach
nur die Kamera-IDs, in welcher Reihenfolge das sein muss, aber Leute, ich kann das nicht
weitermachen, weil ich muss mal ganz, ganz dringend aufs Klo und danach was futtern,
Anti-Ayaya, Gegenteil-Ayaya, heute vielleicht machen wir heute Abend noch, noch ein Schlafstream,
mal gucken, ich geh jetzt erstmal aufs Klo was essen, war schön, dass ihr dabei gewesen
seid, wir sehen uns, bis zum nächsten Mal, machts gut, see you.